خمسه سيناريوهات للحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا
بين المكاسب والخسائر احيانا هبوطا وصعودا
يسر كل طرف حتى اللحظه على استمرار الحرب
فرديه ثانيه وهي اعلان وقف ليطلاق النار
من جانب روسيا مع الاكتفاء بما تحقق من
مكاسب فالرئيس الروسي حقق بالفعل جزءا قل
او كثر مما كان يسعى اليه
كموا الخسائر البشريه والماديه ترويق
الطرفين في ما استنفذ جيش البلدين قدرته
ما في ظل معاناه من نقص في القوه البشريه
والعسكريه نقص لم يعد يبرر خوض المزيد من
القتال
تخالف اوكرانيا التوقعات تنتصر في الحرب
وتجبر القوات الروسيه على الانسحاب الى
المواقع التي كانت عليها سابقا
روسيات تحقق انتصارا محتملا تحكم قبضتها
على كل الاراضي الاوكرانيه بما في ذلك
العاصمه كييف
بين سيناريوهات المحتمله وما هو على الارض
يتضح ان فصول هذه الحرب لم تكتمل بعد عصام
عبد السلام العربيه